El perdedor es bastante obvio.
Es mandoneado, se encoge, se esconde en el rincón.
Muchas veces, cuando hay contacto inicial,
si uno de ellos está demasiado a la defensiva,
el segundo lo clavará, intentar agarrar su tentáculo y ver,
"Oye, ¿quieres pelear conmigo? ¿Quieres darte vuelta?
¿Quieres luchar cuerpo a cuerpo?"
Entonces, lo clava y se va.
Vuelve, lo clava y se va.
(Suena campana de boxeo)
[Regla 2: Evita el contacto visual]
Cuando los pulpos se acercan para empezar a pelear,
no se miran cara a cara.
Se acercan de costado.
El pulpo a la defensiva intenta no mirar al agresor
hasta el punto crucial cuando sabe que es imposible evitar una pelea.
GG: ¿Sí? ¿El que espera hasta el último minuto está a la defensiva?
IC: Sí.
(Suena campana de boxeo)
[Regla 3: Muestra tus colores]
El agresor en una pelea mostrará rápido y claramente
un negro vívido en los brazos
cuando está a punto de iniciar la pelea.
(Suena campana de boxeo)
GG: Oh, ya vemos...
IC: Estamos viendo acción.
Parece que se han visto.
GG: Sí. Ahora va a venir... se le está acercando, pero no directamente.
IC: Sí, están casi completamente...
anti paralelos.
GG: Y luego... ahora.
IC: Sí, hacen contacto y luego sus brazos colisionan.
(Música de cuerdas)
GG: Hemos tomado los primeros pasos para entender el combate del pulpo.
Quizás te estés preguntando, "Pero ¿por qué importa esto?"
Bueno, estos tipos de preguntas de investigación basadas en la curiosidad
muchas veces conducen a ideas y descubrimientos inesperados.
Hemos aprendido mucho de nosotros mismos estudiando los animales marinos.
El calamar nos enseñó sobre cómo se comunican nuestras neuronas;
el cangrejo herradura, sobre cómo funcionan nuestros ojos.
Entonces no es una exageración decir que algunos de los comportamientos
que vemos en los pulpos de dos manchas de California
son similares a los nuestros.